[Music]
hi everyone its charlie we got our first
teaser for the Loki Avengers end game
spin-off series it's gonna be happening
in the next couple of years so we also
know what's going up with the story I'll
break everything down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the Marvel videos we're doing
a new round of that Avengers game
giveaway because of what's going on
during e3 all you have to do to enter
that is just be a subscriber and leave a
comment about Avengers or the Loki
series on the video Marvel had a big
conference a little while ago that was
super private for investors only as part
of their big Disney Plus reveal Kevin
Feige did a huge presentation explaining
all of the Avengers spin-off series that
are happening in the next couple of
years so that's where all the footage
comes from but Marvel just publicly
released it so I will talk about the
news about the other Avengers spin-off
series like The Scarlet Witch vision
series the Marvel what-if series at the
end of the video we'll talk about the
Loki series first because we also know
what the release schedule is going to be
some of the shows will be dropping in
the next year some of them will take a
little bit longer so starting at the
beginning we finally know what's going
on with Avengers endgame Loki in that
scene of him stealing the tesseract and
then just going off to who knows where
they don't address it at the end of the
movie at all they spend a solid 10
minutes of the movie with the Avengers
and then separately with the ancient one
and Hulk and that scene explaining that
the Infinity stones control the flow of
time you pluck one out of this reality
it creates a whole new timeline
branching out from the original one that
you came from unless you bring that
infinity stone back to the exact moment
you took it from which is the whole
reason Captain America has that scene at
the end of Avengers endgame where he
goes back in time to return all the
different Infinity stones to where they
join them from we can only wonder what
the conversation was like when he went
back to form here to return the soul
stone just catching up with the Red
Skull after all these years but as we
all saw this version of Loki from the
events of the original Avengers movie in
2012 takes the tesseract gets the hell
out of Dodge and is completely
unaccounted for at the end of the movie
so now it is canon in the MCU that
there's an alternate reality Loki who
has the tesseract after the events of
the first Avengers movie and we don't
know what happened to him yet which is
where some of this Loki Avengers
spin-off series comes in we know what
the story is and now because of this new
footage we have confirmation of what
it's going to look like in all
address the Asgardians the galaxies Thor
stuff at the end of Avengers endgame
because there will be more Thor stuff
happening in the MCU during Marvel phase
four but we don't know exactly how they
plan to use Loki so we'll talk about
alternate reality tesseract Loki in the
potential for him showing up in future
Thor movies in just a second - so this
is the footage they've released of Kevin
Feige G's presentation of the actual
Loki series it shows Loki back in 1975
while the first jaws movie is in
theaters you see him in the middle of
the street in New York City in front of
the movie theater in a black suit from
Earth the suit is from Earth with the
same green scarf that he was wearing
during the Avengers movie it's pretty
much the entire same outfit that he wore
during the first Avengers movie
[Music]
here's the thing about that though you
remember that even though alternate
reality Loki has the tesseract the space
stone by itself doesn't give you the
ability to travel through time so
clearly this is Loki back during 1975 so
the plot synopsis just goes like this
Loki will be showing up all over the
timeline during major events in world
history influencing them in mischievous
ways it'll be the same version of Loki
just popping up during different years
in each episode or each couple of
episodes depending on how much they
paste the story out but for the most
part each episode will be set during a
different time period and telling a
different story so for instance the Loki
teaser that they released is for the
jaws episode of Loki being during 1975
messing with people enjoying that movie
but also during 1975 in world history it
was noted as the end of the Vietnam War
sounds like Loki will probably have
something to say about that but it was
also the year of the joint Soviet USA
Soyuz space mission still firmly in the
middle of the Cold War which just seems
like a perfect time for Loki to cause
all kinds of trouble then unless it's a
two-part episode in the next episode
he'll be in a different time period
messing with the major events of that
year they announced the release date is
supposed to be sometime during year two
of the Disney streaming service so that
just means sometime between the end of
next year and spring 2021 so it'll take
a little bit longer for them to get the
series out they probably won't start
shooting it for a while some of the
Marvel Avengers shows will roll out next
year some of them won't drop till a
little bit later
Loki being one of the ones that's later
in the timeline along with the Scarlet
Witch vision series called Wanda vision
which I think is gonna drop after Loki
unless they say something different the
Captain America Falcon Winter Soldier
series is supposed to drop next year so
it'll be one of the first ones we get to
see but the number of episodes for all
the different shows is gonna be a little
bit different there's only gonna be six
episodes of the Falcon Winter Soldier
show but because Elizabeth Olsen got
super chatty we found out what's going
on with the Wanda vision shows Wanda
vision but a title whereas that title
come from it comes well there's quite a
few
other comic books that we're pulling
from and it's gonna be Wanda and the
vision and I think at the Disney Plus
launch chat
they showed a photo of us in the 50s and
I think that's a good teaser it's gonna
be really fun
I'm really excited what's the theme song
oh I don't know but it would be some
sort of like that I thought I thought
that's art shooting where I have you
shot it that's all
yeah Paul and I are really excited they
have a great group of writers and how
many episodes will it be do you know
yeah I think it's total six hours I
don't know it's we don't know how many
episodes of Loki there's going to be but
I'm assuming it'll be just like the
other shows between six and eight
episodes you ask though why is the
episode counts so low why aren't they
doing ten episodes per season the answer
is because they're spending as much
money on these as they would on the
movies hundred plus million dollars
typically Marvel movies nowadays are
around hundred fifty plus million
dollars but that basically means that
each of the series will be like a six
hour movie but the big thing to remember
is that the Kevin Feige said that these
Avengers spin-off shows will influence
the MCU cannon and move it forward so
you would treat them like you would
treat any other movie moving the story
of the MCU forward in the timeline even
though now we're actually getting some
period movies like black widow or the
Eternals but anything set during the
past really just helps recontextualize
events that you look at them differently
like the time-travel scenes during
avengers endgame when they're in the
middle of the original Avengers movie
where you get like extra little moments
like oh wow this is kind of like a
deleted scene from that original
Avengers movie a moment that we never
actually got to see like them in the
elevator going down telling Hulk to take
the stairs a lot of you also had
questions about the other Marvel TV
shows during phase four like what's
going on with agents of shield well
right now that stuff is a completely
different group of people producing it
Kevin Feige himself in the Marvel movie
people will be making all these Avengers
spin-off shows the Marvel TV people that
make agents of shield is a completely
different group of people so I wouldn't
expect too much of the other stuff to
wind in with what's going on with these
Avengers phase
for TV shows but there's still a lot of
questions about what's going on with the
future going forward in the timeline
with this alternate reality version of
Loki because presumably he's still alive
otherwise they would have had some scene
at the end of the movie with Captain
America stealing the tesseract back from
him and taking it back to 2012 the only
way I think that this version of Loki
winds up crossing over with our current
version of Thor in a future movie is
that they get into a really heavy
multiverse stuff because alternate
realities aren't quite the same thing as
different dimensions of the multiverse
but you could think of it in kind of the
same way
hopping different realities is more like
jumping dimensions the way that Rick and
Morty do on that TV show travelling
between realities in the finite curve of
the universe because remember there's
infinite possibilities so theoretically
there's infinite different dimensions
but just for the purposes of
storytelling in the MCU they're trying
to keep it as simple as possible when
talking about that stuff pack your [ __ ]
that's only gonna keep them down for a
little bit Morty you squirrels Morty we
got a good five minutes before they're
backing up on our ass Morty we have to
pack up and move to a new reality Morty
you know we said we could only do that a
couple of times we're over here
so just to be clear the version of Loki
that died at the beginning of Avengers
infinity war was the current version of
Loki that we've been with this whole
time he's not coming back he's still
dead he still made this sacrifice he's
still got a measure of redemption in
trying to save Thor's life but because
Loki is such an amazing character
there's so many more stories to tell
that's why they created a branch reality
Loki with the tesseract during avengers
endgame so there's still a Loki out
there just not the same version of Loki
they even had that funnier scene with
danos when they were trying to work
everything out a wand up being a deleted
scene where he's sitting there talking
to Loki in a longer conversation about
why he has to kill him no I heard that
you were meeting to get in touch with me
but then I heard you were dead
I also heard that you were okay then
various other things but the fact is
Loki you and I are not the sword people
understand sword people fear now I got
the information that I needed now I have
to break your neck it's just the way it
is I'm not I'm just a messenger they'll
be more deleted scenes and stuff like
that when they released the Avengers
endgame blu-ray so no worries I'll do
deleted scene videos later this summer
when that happens they haven't announced
the entire cast for the Loki series but
I'm assuming that most of the regular
characters will come back in small ways
but for the most part it's gonna follow
a Loki around so it's not gonna be like
Thor in every single episode but Chris
Hemsworth will participate a little bit
they'll also probably get Anthony
Hopkins to come back as Odin for a
little bit because it's a period piece
so some of the episodes will be set
during the past and he'll still be alive
same thing with Rene Russo's Frigga
character because he was so much closer
to her growing up than he ever was with
Odin so it'd actually be more important
that you put her on the series
they even had that extra material during
Avengers endgame that sort of canonized
as her as being even smarter than you
thought that she was before even more
clever like she's talking to the
Lebowski version of Thor I was raised by
witches boy I know you're not my four
she's also the one that taught Loki all
of his magic so just expect her to pop
up somewhere during the series - the
only show that's going to be available
at launch at the end of this year in
November is gonna be the Star Wars
Mandalorian TV series of course I'll be
doing episode videos for all these shows
when they come but it's just that the
Star Wars Mandalorian TV series will be
the first one to drop they'll be doing a
d23 panel will they reveal more about
what's going on with all this so we'll
probably get a couple more trailers so
I'll talk about it again then later this
summer if you have big questions about
anything
are there any Marvel videos that you
want me to do let me know in the
comments or name a giveaway winner when
I post new Marvel while you wait for
everything click here for that funny
spider-man far from home
Deadpool scene and you can click here
for that brand new Rick and Morty's
season 4 trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stand awesome
I'll see you
guys tonight